l'halloween réalise une première à
poissy ce dimanche 31 octobre à
l'occasion d'halloween la ville organise
une course inter générationnelle décalé
au programme trois tracés de 1,7 5 et 10
km proposés en centre ville
la parcours en coeur de ville parce
qu'il ya certains commerçants qui sont
encore ouverts et si jamais on a besoin
d'aller chercher une petite brioche pour
pour se ravitailler ou aller boire un
coup on va pas se gêner voilà c'est ça
l'esprit de poissy une course atypique
pour se dépenser dans la bonne humeur
aujourd'hui pas de chronomètre
l'important être nombreux sur la ligne
de départ 270 personnes ont participé
tout déguisés pour l'occasion le zombie
va prendre son temps à prendre du
plaisir avec ses enfants je suis
infirmière aujourd'hui une infirmière
comment dire haute en couleurs est prête
à en découdre voilà c'est le zombie
police moi je suis je sais pas et lui
c'est le squelette une quête
on
joue un peu les candy man je sais pas si
vous voyez le film un peu d'horreur
voilà pour prononcer que trois fois
quand tim année on appareils moi je fais
pas la manière qui des beurs voyez ça se
voit c'est super sympa j'en prends plein
d'activités comme ça tout autour de la
ville et donc du poil au wynn c'était la
bonne occasion
l'événement a mobilisé 80 bénévoles et
agents de la collectivité la nomine reis
2022 est d'ores et déjà prévue